DOCTOR QUIRK NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER ME IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. PARA QUE HAN. BERMAN
BIGELOW. BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH.
BONTA BRO BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DEEP EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA-EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN. JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS
WOULD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PATTY
OCEAN OVER DOSED. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A MOMENT OF REFLECTION.
OVER THE YEARS I'VE ASKED
DOZENS OF CHILDREN WHAT
QUALITIES THEY ADMIRE ABOUT
THEIR PETS. THE QUALITY IS THE
SHARED I FELT WERE WHAT WE LOOK
FOR IN A FRIEND OR FUTURE
SPOUSE. HERE'S WHAT THE
CHILDREN THIS DID. AFTER CUTE
AND CUDDLY. THEY CHOSE FAITHFUL
DEVOTED AND GIVING
UNCONDITIONAL LOVE. RECENTLY I
SPOKE AT THE PLASTER TEMPLE
ANNUAL PET MEMORIAL SERVICE. IT
WAS FOR MANY A TEARFUL SERVICE
FOR OUR PETS IVE SO MUCH IN
ASK FOR SO LITTLE IN RETURN.
HUMAN BEINGS WE OFTEN THINK WE
NEED SO MANY THINGS TO BE HAPPY.
BUT OUR LOVING THAT'S SHOW US
HOW TO BE CONTENT WITH EACH DAY
JUST AS IT IS. THEY ARE THERE
FOR US RAIN OR SHINE HAPPY TO
SEE US WHETHER WE ARE DRESSED
TO IMPRESS WE'RE JUST GONNA IN
THE MORNING. IN ALTHOUGH WE MAY
TRY TO TEACH THEM THINGS. WHEN
WE REFLECT UPON THE PETS WE
HAVE LOVED AND LOST WE SEE THAT
THEY HAVE TAUGHT US SOME OF
LIFE'S GREATEST LESSONS. THEY
HAVE SHOWN US HOW TO LIVE IN
THE MOMENT. HOW TO LIVE
UNCONDITIONALLY. AND IN CARING
FOR THEM WE LEARNED THAT THE
DEEP PAIN OF LOSS IS ONLY EQUAL
TO THE LOVE THAT WE HAVE SHARED.
TRULY MOST MEANINGFUL LESSONS
WE WILL EVER LEARN IN LIFE WE
HAVE LEARNED FROM THE PETS WHO
HAVE BEEN OUR LEVY MEMBERS OF
OUR FAMILIES. AND SOME OF THE
BEST PEOPLE I WILL EVER KNOW
WE'LL HAVE FOUR LEGS AND A TAIL.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. THANK YOU REVEREND WE
ASK GUESTS AND VISITORS REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AS
HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER MAJOR. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. AND ONE
ASIAN- IS ABLE. YES OUR- THANK
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY JANUARY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY THE ASSEMBLY MET AT
SEVEN AM ON WILL CRISTINA
GARCIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIFTY
EIGHT DISTRICT PRESIDING ACTED
CHEAPER SUPERCAB THE DESK WE
INCLUDE KATHLEEN ANN LEWIS
READING THE FONG A PLACE FOR
THE MORNING ROLL CALL
AGUIAR-CURRY IRAQI LET BERMAN.
HARPER BONTA BROUGH. CALDERON
CREATE. CHOOSE MISSOURI MOVES
AND MISTER FLORA SECONDS. AT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
AND REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY. FOR A LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KAMLAGER. AND FOR MATERNITY
LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES.
MISTER CALDERON WHERE A
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TWO
LOSS AND BLOOM CHIU AND COOLEY
TO SPEAK ON IN IN GERMANY
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH OF THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM TWENTY FOUR SB FIFTY
FOUR ALLEN. THE INACTIVE FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY THREE TO
ALLOW ALL BILLS HEARD TODAY
THURSDAY JANUARY TWENTY THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY AND REPORTED TO
THE DESK TODAY OR MONDAY
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH OR
TUESDAY. MAY TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT FROM THE
APPROPRIATE COMMITTEE TO BE
ORDER TO THE SECOND OR THIRD
READING FILE OR TO THE FIRST
DAY CONSENT CALENDAR ONE
LEGISLATIVE DAY PRIOR TO THE
DAY REQUIRED UNDER THE RULES.
MR FLOW. RIGHT SIR YOUR WE WERE
TOLD I'M SECONDS CONSENT
NATURAL COLOR MR FLORA IS
WITHHOLDING MISTER CALDERON
MOVES MISTER BONTA SECONDS ON
THE RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE. IS
IT PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER FLORA NO. IS
CALDERON TASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER FLORA NO. ON THE
PROCEDURAL VOTE SUSPENSION OF
THE RULES. THIS TAKES FORTY ONE.
THE. MISTER CALDERON TO ASKING
FOR NINE MISTER FLOORS ASKING
FOR NOW.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSER
ROLE. ICE FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
THIRTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE AGAIN RECOGNIZED. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORS I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO STRIKE THE FOLLOWING
VETOES FROM THE FILE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB EIGHT FIFTEEN
ELEVEN BLOOM FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHT BE FIFTEEN NINETY
ONE COOLEY FILE ITEM NUMBER OR
AB TWO NINETY SIX BELIEVE. THAT
A NUMBER. FIVE ONE WELL FILE
ITEM FOR SIX A. B. FORTY FOR
THE- FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
ONE THIRTY LOW FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB THREE SIXTY FIVE
CRISTINA GARCIA. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR I AM GIVING A ONE DAY
NOTICE TO REMOVE ITEM A THREE
A. B. SEVEN THIRTY FIVE WELL
THEN. FROM THE TO FILE. THE
CLERK WILL NOTE. MEMBERS WE
HAVE SPECIAL GUEST WITH US IN
THE CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS. MR
MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR
GUESS INTRODUCTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS- IN THE
LEADER'S CHARTER SCHOOL IS A
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH EIGHTH
GRADE SCHOOL FOUNDED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN IN THE HEART OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CITY TYPE
UP. A THEIR PURPOSE IS TO
INSPIRE A NEW GENERATION OF
STUDENTS TRYING TO LEAD BY
EXAMPLE WITH HONESTY INTEGRITY
AND SERVICE WHILE HOPING TO
HIGH STANDARDS FOR ALL. SO I'M
NOT IN HONORED BUILDING THEM
STATUS BASKET HELP ME WELCOME
TO THE FOR TODAY THE SEVENTH
AND EIGHTH GRADERS FROM AND
THEN LEADERS TRIED. THAT GOT.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. ON
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS NINE
THREE THIRTEEN ARE TO BE
CONTINUED. MOVING TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
FILE ITEMS FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
PASS AND RETAIN. THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN. AB.
THREE TWENTY THREE. BY MR DAILY
MEMBERS. PLEASE YOUR ATTENTION
TO MR DAILY THE CLERK WILL READ
AT SOME LEVEL THREE TWENTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER DALY AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. MR DAILY YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS NATURAL DISASTERS
SUCH AS MAJOR EARTHQUAKES ARE
WILD FIRES DO YOU HAVE AN
ENORMOUS IMPACT ON THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL RESOURCES. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS ACCOUNT. TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE BILLS THE
NECESSARY CASH RESERVES TO PAY
THE COST OF IMMEDIATE RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY EVEN DURING AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. BECAUSE THE
TIMING AND AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS. ARE UNCERTAIN
IT'S CRITICAL THAT OUR STATE
HAS THE NECESSARY RESERVES ON
HAND TO RESPOND WITHOUT DELAY
WHEN THERE IS A DISASTER. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS DAILY NEWS
RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER EFFECTIVE
MANAGEMENT AND PREPARED THIS
FOR THE DEVASTATING CHANGES IN
CLIMATE THE CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING IS A PRIORITY FOR
ALL OF US NOT ONLY IS THE
SCIENCE CLEAR BUT THE EVIDENCE
IS MOUNTING THAT WE ARE NOT
EFFECTIVELY PEOPLE. FOR THE
INCREDIBLE HARDSHIP ANY
CALIFORNIANS WILL UNFORTUNATELY
EXPERIENCE. FOR FAMILIES THAT
HAVE LOST EVERYTHING IMMEDIATE
AID CANNOT WAITFOR FEDERAL
TIME LINES AND WE AS A
LEGISLATURE CANNOT RELY ON A
HEALTHY ECONOMY TO BE THEIR
ONLY SOURCE OF SUPPORT.
EFFECTIVE TIMELY AND
SUBSTANTIAL RELIEF IS A MUST
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS IN THEIR
GREATEST TIME OF NEED. FOR
THESE REASONS I REACHED
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON AB THREE TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE SOME ROOM
TO MISS QUIRK SILVA. MISS
COURSE OF YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB THREE
TWENTY THREE MEMBERS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I HAVE HEARD AS I
HAVE MET WITH CONSTITUENTS WHEN
WE TELL THEM THAT WE HAVE
INVESTED AS- OF LEGISLATIVE
BODY IN OUR RAINY DAY FUNDS AND
BUILT THAT FUND UP TILL OVER
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS THAT
GIVES THEM THE CONFIDENCE THAT
WE ARE BEING. FRUGAL WITH THEIR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS NOW ADDING THE
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS ACCOUNT
WOULD BE ANOTHER STEP AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN REACT
SWIFTLY AND WORK WITH OUR
FEDERAL GATE GOVERNMENT FOR
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS SO I TO
SUPPORT THIS AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI THREE TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU MISTER BIRKS
OF A MISSED ROMMEL'S YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MISTER CHAIR. I ALSO
JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY THIS
BILL AND URGING YOUR AYE VOTE
ON BILL AB THREE TWENTY THREE
THE DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
ACCOUNT. MY DISTRICT LIKE
OTHERS IN THE STATE OF
EXPERIENCE THE TREMENDOUS HUMAN
AND FINANCIAL LOSS OF NATURAL
DISASTERS. EMERGENCIES THE-
ASSIST. SHE WENT CANNOT AND
SHOULD NOT WAIT. A DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS ACCOUNT WOULD
ENSURE THAT THE STATE HAS A
RELIABLE FUN TO MEET THE
TREMENDOUS COST OF RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY WHETHER OR NOT FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS IS DELAYED OR
EVEN RECEIVED I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS ROSS.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE ITEM MISTER DAILY YOU
MAY CLOSE. I APPRECIATE THE
EXPRESSIONS OF SUPPORT FOR THE
BELL AND ALL THE CO AUTHORS AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS DAILY WITH
THAT CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A- THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE.
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
CHILD ABOUT. HI IS SEVENTY ONE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERSHIPS BRIEFLY I RECOGNIZE
A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE MISS PEDRO KNOB OUT
AS JOIN US ON THE FLOOR THE
HONORABLE MISTER NAVA THANK.
THERE WAS BACK ON THE FILE FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN. AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY DR QUIRK THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK AND EXPLAIN THE CANNABIS.
DOCTOR QUIRK EMAIL. US BAKER IN
MEMBERS- AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
PREVENTS UNNECESSARY WASTE AND
COST WHILE STILL MAINTAINING
TESTING INTEGRITY BY ALLOWING
FOR BATCH TESTING OF
MANUFACTURING CANNABIS AS%
OPPOSED TO TESTING OF SELECTED
RETAIL PACKAGE REPRESENTATIVE
SAMPLES THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU ARRIVE
ABOUT. THANK YOU THE COURT. IS
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLARK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRED ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASSER RETAIN FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN. FILE I AM NINETEEN.
AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX BY MR
BONTA. OPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS. MR BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A. B.
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX IS A CLEAN
UP BILL TO A LOCAL
REDISTRICTING LOCAL DISTRICT IN
REFORM BILL AB EIGHT FORTY NINE
THAT I AUTHORED LAST YEAR AND
WAS SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR AB
TOLD ME SIX ADS BACK LANGUAGE
THAT WAS NEGOTIATED DURING THE
DRAFTING OF AB FORTY NINE IN
INVER. OUT OF THE OFFICE THIS
PROVIDES ON PUNCH OF CLEAN UP I
WAS. ASKED WE ARE. THANK YOU
MISTER POTTER. DISCUSSION OF A
ON THE I. CAR CLUB. ON OF. THE
DESIRED ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VETERANS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. COULD IS AT ABOUT. CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE
FIFTY THREE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TWENTY
PASS RETAIN. FILE ITEM TWENTY
ONE AC ARE ONE FORTY FIVE I
MISS POWER QUE HAN CORKERY
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE HAND
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO MATERNAL
HEALTH AWARENESS DAY. OKAY HAND
ON THE RESOLUTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT ACR ONE
FORTY FIVE WHICH DECLARES
JANUARY TWENTY THIRD MATERNAL
HEALTH AWARENESS DAY IN
CALIFORNIA. WHETHER YOU
YOURSELF HAVE BEEN PREGNANT
YOU'VE BEEN THE PARTNER SUPPORT
PERSON FOR SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
PREGNANT OR YOU THE PRODUCT OF
A PREGNANCY WE ALL KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL. IT'S
SHOCKING AND COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE THAT THE UNITED
STATES RANKS HIGHEST AMONG
INDUSTRIAL LIES NATION IN TURN
MORTALITY. EVERY YEAR MORE THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED WOMEN DIE AS A
RESULT OF A PREGNANCY OR
DELIVERY COMPLICATIONS. WITH
OTHER OVER HALF OF THESE DEATHS
BEING PREVENTABLE. AS A WOMAN
WHO GAVE BIRTH THREE TIMES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
THREE COMPLICATED PREGNANCY I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TAKEN TO
BECOME A LEADER IN THE EFFORTS
TO LOWER THE RATE AND MATERNAL
MORTALITY. OUR STATE
COLLABORATIVE. ORGANIZATIONS
SUCH AS THE MATERNAL QUALITY
CARE COLLABORATIVE IN BRINGING
AWARENESS MATERNAL HEALTH. BY
ENDING PREVENTABLE MORTALITY
AND CLOSING RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN MATERNITY CARE. THROUGH
THESE EFFORTS CALIFORNIA HAS
DECREASED MATERNAL MORTALITY BY
FIFTY THREE PERCENT. GOING FROM
SIXTEEN POINT NINE DEATHS PER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND MY BIRTH.
TO SEVEN POINT NINE. WHAT WE
ARE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IT IS CLEAR WE STILL
HAVE EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
WORK TO DO. PARTICULARLY AMONG
BLACK. AMERICAN INDIAN AND
ALASKA NATIVE WOMEN WHO DIED A
RATE THREE TO FOUR TIMES HIGHER
THAN WHITE WOMEN FROM PREGNANCY
OR DELIVERY COMPLICATIONS. EACH
OF US SHOULD WALK INTO A
HOSPITAL TO GIVE BIRTH AN EQUAL
CHANCE OF. IF WE SPOKE IN
FUNDING RESEARCH MANY BARRIERS
TO RISK APPROPRIATE CARE.
INCLUDING DEPRESSION DISORDER
SCREENINGS AND INSURING SAFE OF
STRUCTURED ACCESS IN OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES. BY DECLARING TODAY
MATERNAL HEALTH AWARENESS DAY
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND I HOPE
TO BRING GREATER AWARENESS TO
WHAT IS WORKING ND WHAT STILL
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO FURTHER
DECREASE MATERNAL MORTALITY AND
IMPROVE MATERNAL HEALTH FOR ALL
WOMEN. ASK YOU A VOTE AND OF
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. THANK YOU MISS POWER
THEY HAVE. SEEING NO MEMBER
SEEKING RECOGNITION TO SPEAK ON
THE RESOLUTION. IS PARA QUE
HANDS ASKING THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION CORPORAL MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ON A ZERO ONE FORTY
FIVE. WORK WELL CLOSER ALL.
THERE ARE SEVEN EIGHT ONE CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED
SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WHILE
I'M TWENTY TO PASS RETAIN. ON
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEMS
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY FOUR
PASS AND RETAIN THAT MOVES US
TO CONSENT CALENDAR. IS A
MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CHECKING HEARING ON. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND EXAM
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE FORTY ONE BY
SOME MEMBER KALRA AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO INDIA REPUBLIC DAY.
CLARK WELL THE ROLLING CONSENT
ALL MEMBERS ABOUT DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CLERK
WELL CLOSE ROLE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. BRIEFLY MOVING THROUGH
ANNOUNCEMENTSMEMBERS
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING UPON A GERMAN AND
ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO UPON A
GERMAN IMPORTED TO A TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY JANUARY TWENTY FOURTH NO
FLOOR SESSION- CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH
FLOOR SESSION. IS AT ONE PM. IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED. I WAS IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS WE ARE
AT ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
EVERY PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES WE
WILL BE ADJOURNING IN THE
MEMORY. PLEASE ALSO REMOVE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS FROM THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION.
TO MR CHU WHO WILL BE A TURNING
IN THE MEMORY MR CHILL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES IT IS WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I ALSO WE
ADJOURN TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF
TERENCE HALLINAN A TRULY ICONIC
LEADER IN SAN FRANCISCO. MR
HELL MAN WAS AN ACTIVIST A
FORMER MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ARE FORMER DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. DURING HIS CAREER IN
PUBLIC SERVICE THE SECOND OF
SIX CHILDREN BORN TO VIVIAN AND
VINCENT HOW IN. HIS FATHER WAS
A FORMER PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
OF THE PROGRESSIVE PARTY. IN
HIS EARLY DAYS HE WAS A BOXER
AT UC BERKELEY HE ALMOST MADE
THE OLYMPIC TEAM. ANY TOOK HIS
FIGHT INTO THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT. HE EXHIBITED A
PASSION FOR JUSTICE BEGINNING
WITH HIS DEMONSTRATIONS AGAINST
THE HOUSE UNAMERICAN ACTIVITIES
DURING THE RED SCARE AND WITH
THE CAMPAIGN FOR NUCLEAR
DISARMAMENT. DURING THESE TIMES
HE LED CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE
MOVEMENTS TO STAND UP FOR THOSE
WHO LACKED REPRESENTATION IN
OUR DEMOCRACY. AS A PRACTICING
ATTORNEY HE CHAMPION CAUSES
WELL BEFORE THEIR TIME.
TRANSGENDER ITES CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM PACIFISM. HE WON
A SEAT ON THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE HE WAS
ELECTED AS DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
OUR CITY. ONE OF THE FIRST TRUE
PROGRESSIVE PROSECUTORS IN THE
UNITED STATES. I WORK FOR HIM
AS A YOUNG PROSECUTOR. HE
SHOWED US THAT YOU COULD FIGHT
CRIME AND STILL BE TRUE TO YOUR
PROGRESSIVE VALUES. A FIERCE
ADVOCATE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS HE
DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO PUBLIC
SERVICE AND I KNOW YOU WILL
JOIN ME IN EXTENDING OUR
DEEPEST SYMPATHIES TO HIS
FAMILY. HIS FRIENDS AND HIS
LOVE ONES I ASKED WE ADJOURN
TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF TERROR
TONY. THANK YOU ISSUE. MR
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO JOIN
IN MEMORY OF CAMERA TAMMY
THATCHER. A FIREFIGHTER WITH
THE SACRAMENTO FIRE DEPARTMENT
ASKED WAY ON NOVEMBER TWENTY
SIX AT THE AGE OF FIFTY ONE
AFTER A LONG FIGHT WITH
MELANOMA AN OCCUPATIONAL CANCER.
FOR THE FAMILY WE PROVIDE A
MORE RESOLUTIONS I WANT TO READ
ONE PARAGRAPH IN AND THEN
PROCEED WITH MY REMARKS.
RESOLUTION OPEN SAY WHERE'S
WITH IMMENSE SADNESS AND A DEEP
SENSE OF LOSS. THE WORD WAS
RECEIVED OF THE DEATH ON
NOVEMBER TWENTY SIX TWENTY
NINETEEN. A FIREFIGHTER TIMBRE
THATCHER OF THE CIRCLE FIRE
DEPARTMENT. A DISTINGUISHED
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT WHOSE
CHARACTER AND DEEDS IN LIFE.
MERRITT GRATITUDE RESPECTFUL OF
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT BY THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT- RAP BECAUSE
OF THAT EMPHASIS UPON CHARACTER.
WHEN YOU THINK OF THE
FIREFIGHTER PROFESSIONS. YOU
KNOW PEOPLE REVEAL THEIR
CHARACTER. MY PERSISTENCE IN
DOING GOOD. AND OF COURSE IF
YOU'RE IN THE FIREFIGHTING
PROFESSION. ASSISTANCE IN DOING
GOOD MEANS YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT YOU ARE READY. FOR
THAT NEXT STEP. THERE IS NO
SLACK TIME IN THE FIREFIGHTING
PROFESSION YOU ARE ENGAGE IN
YOUR WORK YOU ENGAGE IN
TRAINING WE ARE DEVOTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT ALL OF YOUR
EQUIPMENT IN ORDER. THIS IS
PROFESSIONS RATHER OLD OLD CHAU
MCIVER. AS MUCH AS YOU TRAIN.
YOU DO NOT KNOW WHAT PROBLEM
YOU'LL HAVE TO SOLVE ON THE
SIDE OF A FIRE. UNTIL YOU WERE
THERE. AND YOUR ABILITY TO
CONJURE. SOLUTION IS ENTIRELY
DEPEND UPON YOUR READINESS.
YOUR EQUIPMENT YOUR PREPARATION.
SO IN A VERY UNIQUE WAY I THINK
TO BE A FIREFIGHTER IS TO HAVE
YOUR CHARACTER ALWAYS BEING
TESTED SHOWN BY YOUR TEACHER IN
YOUR WORK. AND THIS WAS
CERTAINLY TRUE IN THE CASE OF
TEMAS STATURE SHE ROSE IN THIS
TEAM OF HER COLLEAGUES. IN HER
DEPARTMENT. BECOMING A TRAINING
OFFICER. AT MENTOR WORKING ON.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES AT ALL
MANNER OF THINGS AND AS A LOOK
AS A WOMAN. SEEKING TO
ENCOURAGE OTHER WOMEN ENTER THE
PROFESSION. SO I THINK ON A DAY
LIKE THIS WE RECALL TAMMY
THATCHER FOR THE CHARACTER LONG
DISPLAYED IN OUR THIRTY ONE
YOUR CAREER WITH A CIRCLE OF
FIRE DEPARTMENT. TRANSPLANT
CHARACTER OF BEING A
FIREFIGHTER. IS IT WE KNOW THAT
TO BE A FIREFIGHTER IS EXPOSED
TO ALL MANNER OF CHEMICALS. IN
FIRES FROM VEHICLES PLASTICS
THE HEIGHTEN YOUR EXPOSURE JUST
THE LAST FEW YEARS A NATIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH AGENCY HAS
A TERMINAL CANCER DIAGNOSES
INCREASE OF- FIREFIGHTER 9% OF
THE GENERAL POPULATION AND
DEATHS 14% SO THIS SYSTEMS IN
CHARACTER IN DOING GOOD TO MEET
THE DEMANDS OF THE PRO PERFECT.
ALSO PERSISTENCE IN CHARACTERS
POSED. TWO HAZARDS WHICH JUST
ANOTHER WHAT LENDS TO LOOK AT
THE CHARACTER THAT ALL OF THIS
PROFESSION RELATE TO AND AS HER
FAMILY AND FRIENDS ARE IN THIS
CHAMBER TODAY. I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
IN THE FIRST YEAR THAT THIS
ELEGANT CHAMBER WAS RESTORED
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC THAT WAS HE
THAT ARE TWELVE YEARS WORK WITH
BRIAN MY NEW. ASH THE BILL TO
RECOGNIZE. CANCER IS NOT PREFER
HAZARD IN THE PHARMACY
PROFESSION. IT WAS PASSED ON
THE FOR THIS CHAMBERS IN THE
FALL OF NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AND
SIGNED INTO LAW BY GOVERNOR
BROWN. SO THE CONTINUE TAMMY
WAS BORN ON FEB OR TWENTY SEVEN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT IN CULVER
CITY. AND MOVED TO SECOND ON
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. SHE
ATTENDED ELK GROVE HIGH SCHOOL
WHERE SHE EXCELLED IN ATHLETICS.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM CIRCLE
CITY COLLEGE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. SHE BEGAN HER THIRTY ONE
YEAR CAREER TO SEVERAL FAR
APART. SHE WAS A ROLE MODEL IN
THE DEPARTMENT HAVING SERVED AS
A FIREFIGHTER TRAINING OFFICER
PARAMEDIC. SUPPORT CANCER AND
CAPTAIN. SHE HAD AN UNMATCHED
SENSE OF HUMOR AND WAS WELL
LOVED BY OUR COLLEAGUES AS WE
SEE REFLECTED IN THE CHAMBERS
THIS MORNING. ALWAYS ONE TO
SUPPORT HER COLLEAGUES TâM WHO
WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
FOUNDATION. OF THIS SACRAMENTO
FIRED APPROACH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH UNIT. TO HELP
FIREFIGHTERS DEAL WITH THEIR
PERSONAL STRUGGLES. TAMMY A
SURVIVOR HER PERSONAL DEBT
SANDOVAL GEORGE STATURE. HER
STEPFATHER MIKE SANDOVAL
SISTERS DEADLY JOHNSON NIECE
BAILEY WEEZER JOHNSON AND MANY
EXTENDED SIBLINGS COUSINS AUNTS
AND UNCLES. TAMMY WAS SELFLESS
IN HER PURSUIT OF PUBLIC
SERVICE. AND SHE LEAVES BEHIND
AN INCREDIBLELEGACY THE SECOND
WE WILL SORELY MISS HER.
FOREVER ATER HER SERVICE. AND
WITH THAT COLLEAGUES I ASKED WE
JORDAN HER MEMORY TODAY. THEY
IMAGE COOLEY AND MISTER COOPER
YOU TWO ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
GERMAN A MEMBER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. AND MEMBERS I
TOO WOULD LIKE TO GET MY
RESPECT IN THE PACIFIC THE TO
MERE THATCHER'S FRIENDS AND
FAMILY. THROUGHOUT MY CAREER I
FOR THE HONOR OF SERVING BESIDE
SECOND CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT
FIRE FIGHTERS. THERE SOME OF
THE MOST CARING HARDWORKING.
INTO MAYOR WAS. KEVIN THATCHER
WAS THE HERO IT WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED. MY THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS
ARE WITH THE ENTIRE MITCHELL
FAMILY AND HER FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER COOPER.
AND MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS- I RISE TODAY TO GERMAN
IN THE MEMORY OF ONE OF THE
GREATEST ROCK DRUMMERS OF ALL
TIME NEIL PERK OF THE ROCK BAND
RUSH YOU PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
SEVENTH. BORN IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO IN ONTARIO OKAY NEIL
PER START HIS MUSIC CAREER BY
PLAYING READ THIS THE PAIR OF
CHOPSTICKS JUST LIKE. THIS CASE.
IS PARENTS BOUGHT A DRUM SET WE
CAN PROBABLY ALL BE GRATEFUL
THAT MIND DID NOT. BUT EVEN TEN
YEARS LATER NEIL PART ADDITION
FOR RUSH A CANADIAN PROGRESSIVE
ROCK BAND THAT WAS THEN ON THE
RISE. IN HIS TIME WITH RUSH HE
WROTE FOR EIGHTEEN OF THE
BAND'S STUDIO ALBUMS AND DURING
THAT TIME ALSO PUBLISH SEVEN
MEMOIRS OF HIS TRAVELS. THE
LYRICS NOVELS WERE BUYS DEEP
LOVE OF LITERATURE HISTORY AND
POLITICS IN HIS WORDS ENCOURAGE
FANS TO FIND THEIR
INDIVIDUALITY. AND EXPRESSED A
VULNERABILITY THAT THEY CAN
RELATE TO. MOVIE PROBABLY KNOW
THEIR SONGS LIKE FLY BY NIGHT
AND SPIRIT OF RADIO AND- YOU
MIGHT HAVE EVEN AIR DRUMS TO
THEIR BIGGEST HIT TOM SAWYER
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
LISTEN TO THAT SONG AND THE
NEXT TIME IT COMES ON THE RADIO
OR- BUT- TO. FIVE EIGHT INNING
OF HURT. IT IS ABSOLUTELY
SUBLIME AND CARRIES THAT SONG
AND SO MUCH OF RUSSIA'S MUSIC.
AS RUSHED QUICKLY ROSE TO THE
TOP OF THE CHARTS. FACE TRAGEDY
AT HOME IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN HIS DAUGHTER WAS KILLED
IN A DEVASTATING CAR ACCIDENT
AND ALMOST A YEAR LATER HIS
WIFE PASSED AWAY FROM CANCER.
GRIEVING FOR HIS FAMILY NEIL
TOOK A HIATUS FROM THE BAND
AND- COULDN'T STAY ALONG A AWAY
FOREVER THOUGH AND AFTER A FEW
YEARS HE RETURNED TO THE BAND
AND HELP RUSH RELEASED THEIR
SEVENTEENTH ALBUM. THE ALBUM
VAPOR TRAILS REACHED NUMBER TEN
IN THE BILLBOARD CHARTS.
OFTENTIMES NEIL PART WAS
DESCRIBED AS AN OUTSIDER AND
THE MUSIC THAT RUSH MADE WAS
CONSIDERED. MUSIC FOR NERDS.
BUT I THINK WHAT MADE RUSHED
ONE OF THE GREATEST ROCK BANDS
WAS THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE SONGS
THAT WERE ODDLY RELATABLE AND
PURCHASE POWERFUL DRUMMING IN
LYRICS WERE AT THE HEART OF.
RUSH WAS ELECTED INTO THE ROCK
AND ROLL HALL OF FAME IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND THE PART HAS BEEN
NOTED BY ROLLING STONE MAGAZINE
AS THE FOURTH. GREATEST DRUMMER
OF ALL TIME. BEHIND THREE
LUMINAIRES GINGER BAKER KEITH
MOON AND JOHN BONHAM. THE
ELIXIR FIVE BY HIS WIFE
CARRYING HIS DAUGHTER OLYMPIA
LOUISE AND ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THIS MEMORY. YOU
MISTER BLOW MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES THE DESK TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL OUR
REQUEST TO RETURN MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SINGING HEARING OF
FOR THE BUSINESS ALREADY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR PATERSON MOVES AND MISTER
BONTA SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
JANUARY TWENTY STE. AT ONE PM
WE ARE RETURNED.
A PATTERSON
VOTE CHANGE- FILE NINETEEN AB
ONE TWO SEVEN SIX I TO NOT
VOTING. THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX I TO NOT
VOTING.